[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es eine
richtig leckere raffaello torte besser
gesagt eine saftige kokosnuss torte die
torte besteht aus einem saftigen biscuit
boden zusammengestellt mit einer richtig
leckeren schoko sahne creme und getobt
habe ich das ganze noch mit kokos chips
wir bereiten zuallererst die kokons
creme zu und hierfür benötigen wir kalte
schlagsahne magerquark mascarpone
kokosraspeln sahne stand mit etwas
butter zucker und vanille extrakt
[Musik]
die zubereitung ist ziemlich
unkompliziert denn wir fahren jetzt
magerquark mascarpone puderzucker und
vanille extrakt ganz kurz miteinander
bis es sich alles verbunden hat
[Musik]
nach ein paar sekunden geben wir die
kalte schlagsahne mit dazu und es ist
wirklich wichtig dass die sahne ganz
frisch aus dem kühlschrank kommt und
richtig richtig kalt ist
anschließend geben wir noch dass seine
stand mittel mit hinzu und schlagen das
ganze so lange bis es eine schöne feste
creme ergibt
[Musik]
achtet bitte darauf dass ihr das ganze
nicht zu lange röhre denn ansonsten wird
die creme gruselig und das wollen wir
nicht
nun gehen wir noch die kokosraspeln
mithin zu rühren das ganz kurz noch
unter und dann ist die leckere kokos
creme auch schon fertig
[Musik]
und nun zeige ich euch schon die
weiteren zutaten das sind erneut kalte
schlagsahne und sahne stand mittel
außerdem raphael los desweiteren
benötigen wir kokos chips und gehobelte
mandeln und so schmücken die mandeln
noch gar nicht lecker wir rüsten sie
vorher in der pfanne an
[Musik]
die kalte schlagsahne schlage ich mit
dem sahne stand mittel steif und gebe
sie bis zur weiterverarbeitung in den
kühlschrank
auch die gehobelte mandeln bereite ich
schon mal vor
dafür gebe ich sie in eine fett lose
fahne am besten sollte die beschichtet
sein und risse sie bei mittlerer stufe
von allen seiten an
so sehen die mandeln doch schon viel
besser aus und die gebe ich jetzt zum
auskühlen an die seite weiter geht's mit
unserem biscuit boden das rezept hierzu
findet ihr bereits auf einem kanal das
video verlinkt ich euch
selbstverständlich hier im bild und auch
nochmal in der infobox
ich habe an der stelle zwei drittel des
rezepts genommen und dem boden einmal
durch geteilt damit für zwei bühnen
erhalten ein biskuit boden gebe ich
jetzt auf die tortenplatte und lege ein
tortenring drumherum
[Musik]
den tortenboden trinke ich jetzt mit
einer mischung aus milch und macadamia
sirup der kokosnuss sirup findet der
kann den selbstverständlich auch
verwenden und sobald wir den boden dann
gedrängt haben geben wir kokos chips
darüber
nun kommt darüber die hälfte der
leckeren kokos creme und wird glatt
gestrichen
[Musik]
anschließend wird darüber der zweite
biscuit boden gelegt und mit der milch
mischung gestrichen
[Musik]
wer keinen sirup da hat der kann
selbstverständlich auch nur milch über
die bühnen geben das macht sie auch
schön saftig
nachdem auf den zweiten boden erneut
kokos tipps gegeben wurden geben wir die
zweite hälfte der cocos creme darüber
allerdings geben wir vier esslöffel der
creme zur seite denn die benötigen wir
noch für den rand der torte
[Musik]
nachdem die oberfläche schön glatt
verstrichen wurde
geben wir die torte zum kühlen für eine
halbe stunde in den kühlschrank
nach der schulzeit wird die torte vom
tortenring befreit und die ränder werden
mit der restlichen creme eingestrichen
[Musik]
an der stelle müsst ihr gar nicht ganz
so gerade und sauber arbeiten denn die
ränder werden später sowieso noch mit
den gehobelte mandeln bedeckt
[Musik]
gebt nun die gehobelte mandeln an den
rand und drückt sie mit den händen an
wichtig ist dass für diesen schritt die
mandeln schon komplett ausgekühlt sind
nun teile ich die torte in 14 gleich
große stücke ein und gebe auf jedes
stück einsame tupfen
[Musik]
auf jedes leckeres stück torte gebe ich
dann noch ein raffael und schmücke die
mitte der torte mit kokos chips
[Musik]
und das ist unsere fertige kokosnuss
raffaello torte bis zum anschnitt sollte
sie jetzt im kühlschrank gelagert werden
und dann könnt ihr euch sie schmecken
lassen
ich bin mir sicher dass diese torte vor
allem kokos fans besonders gut schmecken
wird falls ihr mehr von mir sehen
möchtet dann abonniert mich kostenlos
und folgt mir gerne auf instagram bis
zum nächsten mal auf dieses kitchen